aaron rodgers if you haven't heard has a
new contract teddy bridgewater if you
haven't heard
has another new team and we're going to
break it up into two halves rogers then
bridgewater so let's start with what's
going on with aaron rodgers he does
indeed have a new contract as broken by
james jones former packers receiver it
is considered poor form to speculate on
who the sources may be of members of the
media so i will not engage in such
irresponsible speculation that james
jones got this information directly from
aaron rodgers himself
you would think at least a phone call
would be made hey aaron i have some
other unnamed source that's saying you
have this new contract and it's worth
this much money am i wrong
regardless he's not wrong it's a
four-year extension
and it's worth 33.5 million per year in
new money we've just been down this new
money rabbit hole with odell beckham jr
the difference between new money and
total value at signing aaron rodgers had
two years left on his prior contract
when you put what he was due to make
with what he will make and you slap it
together it becomes a six-year
176 million dollar deal
which isn't bad right i think he'll be
okay
if he invests wisely he probably will
have enough money for himself and a
generation or five of roger's progeny
some details about the contract itself
which i obtained from a source with
knowledge of the deal who is not aaron
rodgers i will not disclose my sources
but i can tell you this
the following information did not come
from mr aaron rodgers how about a
signing bonus of 57.5 million that's a
record by seven and a half million last
year matthew stafford got 50 aaron
rodgers 57.5 and that's the best kind of
guaranteed money because you get it
right now
you have it now you don't have to wait
you don't have to be under contract
any time in the future now if you retire
prematurely you have to pay some of it
back and who knows maybe he retires
prematurely and he may have to pay some
of it back we went down that road with
ben roethlisberger last year when he was
talking about retiring and he would have
voted 18 million dollars if he had
before the 2017 season but 57.5 million
to sign
uncle sam's going to get his cut
state of wisconsin is going to get their
cut so he's not like he's walking out of
there with 57.5 million but again i
think he'll be fine
through the end of the season he will
have made 66.9 million and here's the
kicker by next march 80.8 million will
have been paid out or at a minimum
earned by aaron rodgers sometimes
there's deferred compensation in there
but he will have earned from the green
bay packers a publicly traded
corporation which clearly has the money
to afford this specific obligation 80.8
million through march of next year
and it does work out to 176 through six
years 103 million through the first
three years of the deal which if my math
is correct and it rarely is you got a
little front loading here you got 103
for the first three years
73 for the final three years and i'm
going to need the assistance of my
calculator just so i get this right i
should be able to figure it out 73
divided by 3 is 24.3 million a far cry
from
the
33.5 million total average so he's
making a lot of money over the first
three years let's do 103 divided by 3
that's 30 that can't be right 103
divided by 3. that's 34.3 76 divided by
3 is 25.3
the four-year average is 35 something
like that i don't know just hey see this
is what happens when you do math you get
it all screwed up bottom line is he's
getting 103 over the first three years
73 over the last three so when we get to
the final three years if he's still
playing at a high level there's a chance
he's going to feel like julio jones and
what happened with julio jones this year
he looked at the final three years of a
six-year contract and said i'm getting
screwed well no you screwed yourself
because you agreed to the contract and
now we're at the point where you've made
the front loaded portion and now you're
on the back nine or the back three as
the case may be and you're realizing you
got screwed no this is the deal you
agreed to this is what you're making and
there's a chance that aaron rodgers may
not be thrilled with his contract when
we get to the point that he is making
those final three years of the
of the deal that he now has signed that
again will take him through 2023. now a
couple of things real quick
this isn't
a record-shattering deal it's a setting
deal
33.5 million is three and a half million
more per year than matt ryan that moves
the bar north but it's not so far north
that at some point the next four or five
years someone won't pass it especially
in new money that fictional assessment
of what a deal is worth when it comes
down to total value he's at 29.3
and that's not much more than matt
ryan's total value of 28.2 which wasn't
much more than kirk cousins 28. and
that's what's important here kirk
cousins 28 million fully guaranteed over
three years that's 84 million i know
because i've previously done that math
84 million over three years now aaron
rodgers is going to make 103. he's
making 19 million more over the next
three years but but
remember that's 73 on the back end and
remember kirk cousins going back to the
open market and the way that the vikings
have structured this deal and there's
either a no franchise tag clause in
there and as a practical matter it will
be impossible to transition tag him
whatever the case may be the way the
cousin's deal is structured he's going
back to the market in three years
so he'll have 84 in hand
and
when you look at the base deal of 176
he needs 92 million
over the next three years once he hits
the open market again and when you
consider the jets offered him 90 million
over three and he said no the salary
cap's going to go up the market's going
to go up if cousins continues to play at
an acceptable level not even a top five
or top 10 level just acceptable he's
going to get
92 million over the next three years so
i think there's a very good chance that
kirk cousins ends up making more than
176
over the next six years which means that
aaron rodgers left money on the table
left meat on the bone and that's fine
that's his prerogative but when we heard
all these rumblings about having
flexibility and different ways and
creativity and things that can be done
versus the meat and potatoes approach
that the packers like to take meat and
potatoes won the day here there's
nothing creative there's nothing that
protects aaron rodgers it pays him a
load of money
but there's a chance that kirk cousins
who doesn't even belong in the same
sentence as aaron rodgers from a talent
and accomplishment standpoint sorry kirk
but you you kirk kirk knows i mean
really what's he going to say i'm as
good as aaron rodgers come on we we all
know but he may make more over the next
six years than aaron rodgers because of
the fact that he will go back to the
market in three years
you